someone who stole a very expensive
vehicle
shut up we don't ever outside its a
next-gen prototype with all the bells
and whistles
if thousand whistles could explode and
murder people stop this maniac
Tuesday January 15th on the CW hey
everybody its charlie Happy New Year
surprise surprise we got another brand
new flash trailer right after I did a
reverse flash trailer this is another
one for episode 10 even though you don't
see reverse flash in here anywhere
there's still a lot of that going on
during the episode so I'll explain and
we got to talk about a new Norah
WTF theory about her endgame in this
whole crisis on Infinite Earths plan
that she and the reverse-flash are
trying to pull off there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite flash moment on the
video well break down the new footage
first there's a couple Easter eggs in
here then I'll talk about the noir
theory first big thing you'll notice
weather is back she's got her
weather control rod hanging off of her
back the reason why they put this shot
in here so that he would immediately
identify her even if you don't quite
remember that episode because she was
wearing a different costume
now they got like the full thickness
going on with their leather jackets and
they've gone full Fast and Furious so
the title of the episode as you can
imagine is the flash and furious it's a
very obvious reference to all the car
stuff that they have going on during the
episode in present day but it's also a
reference to what's going on with Nora
in the future with the reverse-flash as
you can imagine based on the footage
from the last trailer it's reverse flash
who's the furious one in that two-person
equation I don't know who this other new
character is that seems to be leading
the car heist at Argus but they've just
created a James Bond Knight Rider
amalgam card that they want to steal I'm
assuming the only reason that Argus
would build themselves a James Bond car
is because Diggle really wanted one in
Lyla just happened to approve it on
their budget seat or if it's some sort
of meta tech that they're just
experimenting with so that it will help
them take down other metas like remember
the big thing this season that creates
the new metas is the meta tech that's
where weather which gets her powers from
she doesn't naturally have the ability
to control the elements in the way that
her father weather wizard does but even
though most of this footage focuses on
Nora seeming like she's trying to take
them down by her selves like she easily
dodges the rocket that comes out of the
grille but usually what happens is is
that Nora gets some sort of GI Joe style
lesson like knowing is half the battle
so the typical rhythm of an episode is
that she's trying to do something by
herself or just rushes in too quickly
she learns a lesson then she somehow
solves the problem by the
into the episode so even though the car
by itself doesn't seem like a huge
threat to her I'm assuming that the car
in conjunction with the abilities that
weather which has is just too much for
her to handle by herself you do see
Barry in costume with killer frost
behind him so they're obviously a big
part of the episode too but because of
all the Nora Hannibal Lector
reverse-flash
Silence of the Lambs stuff happening in
the future it just feels like more of
the plot the back half of the season is
gonna be turning around what she's doing
until Barry eventually finds out what
she's doing like eventually he has to
learn that the reverse-flash is helping
Nora she's doing it for good reason
trying to save her father from dying
during crisis on Infinite Earths but
he's still probably gonna crap his Flash
pants something fierce when he finds out
but for the most part it just seems like
there's some sort of mini rogue team-up
that's happening in this episode the
producer said at Comic Con they were
introducing younger versions of the rows
where the which is a really good example
that I couldn't find any IMDB entries
for this actress here so I don't know if
she's playing a comic book character so
I don't want to speculate too much about
what she's gonna be doing in the future
of the show or if she's just a one-off
character that you only see in this
episode but it seems like they're
spending a whole lot of time developing
the weather which character so whatever
happens with this girl it does seem like
weather which will continue to be a big
force on the show as far as we know
though I think the more interesting
thing going on during the episode is in
learning more about what's going on
between Nora in reverse-flash I think
they're just trying to avoid putting as
much of that in the trailers as possible
so they don't give it away ahead of time
but the big mystery with those two
characters isn't so much the why of it
all like we know why Nora is working
with reverse-flash she wants to save her
father from dying during crisis on
Infinite Earths it's the what in the how
like how are they gonna do that without
completely messing up the timeline and
how was reverse-flash gonna get himself
out of this pickle like the whole idea
of legacy I talked about in my last
reverse-flash trailer video there was a
big interview the Tom cabin on the
producers did talking just about eobard
thawne so there's this whole question of
whether or not he's trying to turn good
even though we know from Nora's
newspaper he winds up being pretty evil
during crisis on Infinite Earths so
which is this really cool cat-and-mouse
game they'll be playing this season that
I think will probably be one of the more
interesting arcs that they've ever done
on the TV show talking about the new
Nora
WTF theory remember during the hundredth
episode where they go back and they're
talking
- EU Barth on and he starts questioning
them about who this mystery girl is that
he brought with him who's your friend
I guess Jessie chambers
no maybe Lauren wait Danika William it
doesn't matter
oh she is
is your daughter
you've brought me your daughter
it's uh dawn if I'm not mistaken Nora
[Music]
Noora
that's nice at least you still have one
the really important thing about that
scene is that it foreshadows NORs
endgame because of when it happens and
the version of eobard thawne Harrison
wells that they're talking to is very
critical that it be happening in this
moment with this version of that
character so why is that important well
that's because this version of
reverse-flash has knowledge of the
original untainted timeline before he
came back killed Barry's mother creating
an alternate timeline where Barry became
the flash much quicker because
reverse-flash wanted to get home quicker
so he just sped everything up but that
also causes ripple effects so it changed
the timeline in different ways down the
road so this whole season has been all
about Nora making mistakes altering the
timeline because of what
eobard thawne told her to do so reverse
flash is the one that told her to come
back and punch that satellite which
created the new version of cicada and
set them off on the path this season so
there's more butterfly effects the
futures more worse than ever
so when reverse flash here thinks that
she's dawn Allen one half of the tornado
twins and his bemused by the fact that
her name is different it's almost as if
he instantly recognizes what's about to
happen in his own future because none of
this stuff has happened for him yet this
is way earlier in the timeline but it
almost seems like in this moment here
where he like acknowledges Nora like
Nora I'll be seeing you again as if he
has already hatched a plan to get back
at Barry in some way in the future so
there's a whole lot to unpack there one
the idea that he knows that Nora might
be something that he can exploit in the
future but also that Nora is not
supposed to exist in the original
timeline
Nora isn't supposed to be Nora she's
supposed to be dawn so here's the big
thing - like Nora seems like a good
character everybody's kind of grown to
love her like team flash has grown to
love her they've gotten close to her as
parents but she's still technically not
the right version of Barry's daughter so
here's what they do with TV shows like
this big dramas is they get you to care
about a character then they try to yank
the rug right out from under you like
you care about Nora she grows as a flash
in her own right learns all these
lessons from her father Barry and you
think that she's going to go back to the
future it'd be this awesome version of
the flash in her future timeline but
remember that conversation that Oliver
Queen had
with the monitor about balance in the
universe in Oliver Queen potentially
sacrificing his own life so that Barry
could live the ultimate payoff for Nora
is is that she cares about her father so
much she becomes a hero and is willing
to give her own life to save him
so remember way back at the beginning of
season for all the jibberish the Barry
was speaking when he said we're going to
need more diapers they still haven't
completely paid off all of those Speed
Force symbols in the gibberish that he
spoke we just found out what the Speed
Force symbols are all about it's a time
language but when he says we're gonna
need more diapers it seems like what the
payoff is going to be for her by the end
of the season if you want to be a little
more hopeful about it and I do think the
show is trying for a hopeful ending is
is that they change things Nora does try
to sacrifice herself but back to the
future style like remember all the Back
to the Future Easter eggs during the
first episode Nora Marty McFly what
ended up happening at the end of Back to
the Future Marty changes the timeline
for the better and his family winds up
being even better than it was off before
so the ultimate payoff for Nora is is
that she makes that ultimate sacrifice
and Nora also gains a brother in the
process so we get to our version of the
tornado twins on the TV show so let me
know in the comments Nora
forced to make the ultimate sacrifice
how do they pay off we're gonna need
more diapers and save Barry from crisis
on Infinite Earths at the same time so
don't be surprised if Nora feels a
little bit selfish right now and slowly
becomes more selfless then eventually is
willing to sacrifice herself but you
know winds up in a much more happy
payoff than you would expect there's a
whole bunch of stuff that's going on
this week Young Justice is starting this
Friday so I've already posted a
non-spoilery review and the first big
scene from the season so click here to
watch that and then click here to
rewatch that reverse-flash trailer video
that i posted yesterday thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]